at a very high level the period between
1915 and 1918 on the western front is
usually considered to be a stalemate
it's considered to be a stalemate
because you did not have a major
movement on the front there were some
movement but the front pretty much
looked the way that it looks in this
diagram right over here that's not to
say that it was not incredibly bloody in
fact it was so bloody that some of the
most famous battles not just in world
war one history but in world history
occurred during this period in
particular
they occurred in 1916.
in 1916 the first of these happened in
february where you have the battle of
verdun or verdun
battle of verdun
where you have the germans who want to
do an offensive on the french that many
hysteric most historians believe was
intended not to necessarily gain this
territory but to try to make the french
put so many troops here and
inflict so many casualties on the french
that they might not be able to overcome
that and they might have to throw the
french out of the war and they
especially thought this part of the
front was vulnerable because the french
could be attacked from multiple sides
this little bulge right over here and so
in february of 1916 they attack
primarily with artillery so they're
shelling the french
right over here this whole area the
french keep bringing troops into the mix
keep bringing troops into the mix and to
get a sense of how ugly and how scary
this whole scene was this is a quote
from the journal of a french soldier who
was serving in verdun during the battle
of verdun or serving in the battle of
verdun and he wrote and he was
unfortunately later killed due to
artillery fire
humanity is mad it must be mad to do
what it is doing
what a massacre what scenes of horror
and carnage i cannot find words to
translate my impressions hell cannot be
so terrible men are mad
and this battle would continue through
most of the year as you go into the
summer that's kind of the maximum of the
german offensive this is some of the
territory that that we that they are
able to capture but as you get into the
late summer in july of 1916 the british
and the french decide to do an offensive
on another part of the front right over
here near the psalm river so this right
over here is the psalm
this right over here is the psalm river
and so you have so this right over here
is a german offensive
german
offensive in july you have the battle of
the psalm
battle sometimes referred to as the
psalm offensive
of
the psalm named after the psalm river
it's where it occurred where the psalm
river intersected with the front
and this was an anglo british and french
anglo french
offensive and it's also famous both of
these were incredibly bloody that's what
really made them noteworthy but this was
also famous for the first use of the
tanks this was a picture of a british
tank at the time but both of these were
incredibly bloody it was lucky for the
french at verdun that the battle of the
the the offensive at the psalm happened
because this forced the the germans to
go off of the offensive as we get into
the late summer of 1916 they had to
bring they had to bring troops back over
here to help support it but the end
result of both of these is you did not
have a major movement of the front in
fact by the end of 1916 because the
germans had to go fight at the battle of
the sum the french were able to
recapture much of this territory so the
real end result of both of these
offensives one on the german side one on
the british side was just a massive
massive massive loss of human life
each of them it's estimated had on the
order of a million casualties roughly
half on each side at verdun it was
slightly more on the french side than
the german but it was roughly you know
55 45 so a million casualties in verdun
a million casualties on both sides at
the psalm i've seen estimates on the
death toll being a third of a million to
half a million for each of these battles
so both of these were incredibly
incredibly ugly battles for both sides
the end result for the germans though
was even more interesting because you
have to remember what was happening at
the eastern front on the eastern front
1916 was the year that the russians
finally were kind of building up their
war machine they were finally able to
equip the munitions necessary it was
also the year that the romanians joined
on the on side of the antant along with
the russians on the eastern front the
austro-hungarians were suffering huge
losses so 1916 the germans were in a
very tough situation huge losses at
verdun huge losses at the battle of the
sam the the russians are starting to get
more aggressive on the eastern front the
austro-hungarians are starting to have
trouble so they decide to essentially
retrench so they're going to start
bringing more troops back to the eastern
front but in order to not hold too much
ground or not to lose too much ground on
the western front they essentially try
to try to hold a smaller front so they
back up to this line they start
preparing so their hol this is this is
this is the line at the end of the
battle of the psalm
the germans recognize that they can't
protect this entire front they want to
protect a a shorter front so they begin
preparing to move back right over here
and they essentially and this line right
over here is named after the field
martian of the j of the of the german
army it's called the hindenburg line
hinden
hindenburg
hindenburg line it's no coincidence it's
the same name of the zeppelin that blew
up in
in the late 30s it was actually named
after field marshal hindenburg over for
whom this line is named but the germans
do this in order so that they can they
can take more troops to the eastern
front and hold a shorter line so by the
end of 1916 they start making the
preparations for the hindenburg line and
in february of 1917 they actually move
back to the hindenburg line so this is
19 1917
february you have the germans
the germans moved to the hindenburg line
hindenburg
line so 1916 incredibly incredibly ugly
year 2 million casualties
not a lot of movement of the actual
front